-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning writer,
actor, and comedian.
Her musical "The Bedwetter"
makes its off-Broadway debut
on May 23rd at
the Atlantic Theater Company.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Sarah Silverman,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-Oh, I'm very good.
I just bumped into
Jeffrey Donovan backstage.
-Yeah, our other guest tonight.
-Very exciting.
-You're a fan.
-I'm a big "Law & Order" fan,
my friend -- "L&O."
-I'm very happy
about this new --
This new "Law & Order"
is wonderful.
-I can't believe it, and he's --
You know, Anthony Anderson,
he's back as Bernard.
-Yep.
-Then Jeffrey is Frank Cosgrove.
-Mm-hmm.
-And he's got great lines.
I watch it every Thursday.
Like, this last one,
he had so many good lines.
Like, he goes --
Anthony Anderson character
Bernard, he goes,
"Hey, nice move out there."
And then Frank goes, "Hey, I
don't sell shoes for a living."
[ Laughter ]
And then I even Googled that,
'cause I go, "Is that a saying?"
But it's not.
-Yeah.
It's a very unique role
that they always need somebody
on "Law & Order" to perform.
It's called the Orbach.
You need the Orbach.
-Yes, that last --
right before the "bow bow."
-Yeah, you've got to
have the guy who's like,
"I'm gonna say
something good enough
that you can 'bow bow' me."
-Then they catch the crook,
and the crook's a real jerk,
you know, and the guy --
and he's putting him
in the cop car,
and the guy goes,
"I want a lawyer."
And Cosgrove goes,
"You're gonna need a priest."
-Oh!
♪ Bow bow ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway...
-Enough about our second guest.
-You're right.
[ Laughter ]
-This is very exciting.
This is based on your memoir
about you being
a 10-year-old bedwetter.
True story.
-Yeah.
-And so now it's a musical,
and there is a young actor
playing a 10-year-old
version of you.
Is that weird to watch?
I mean, I'm sure the whole
process is a little surreal.
-I mean, sure, it's weird,
but we've been working on it.
I've been working on it so long,
10 years, you know,
that it's like, "Wow, she was,
you know, like, little
when we started work."
But this actress is --
Like, she's incredible.
It's crazy to watch.
It is surreal, but now I'm
very used to it, you know.
But she's just --
Her name is Zoe Glick,
and she just carries this
whole show on her shoulders.
She's incredible.
-It's very exciting that
you're opening on Monday.
It's very exciting.
As you said, this is the end
of a long journey of 10 years.
Where did you rehearse
in the city?
-We rehearsed at a rehearsal
hall in Times Square.
-That's very New York.
-So I'm walking her
through Times Square.
And it's so funny because, you
know, Carolines is right there.
-Very famous comedy club, yep.
-Right.
And a kid is passing out flyers
for Carolines.
"Hey, live comedy, live comedy."
And I'm like, "I'm gonna
make this kid's day
'cause he must be
a young comic."
I passed out flyers for
two years when I started out.
So I walk over to him, and I go,
"No, thank you."
And he goes, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
So...
-That's a rough moment.
-Put me in my place.
It's probably good for me.
It was good for me.
-So, you get to sit --
You know, again,
these are previews,
so people,
they're doing the play.
You're getting to watch it.
You're getting to watch it
with an audience,
taking notes in the back.
-Yeah.
-And what is that like?
Do you feel like you're getting
a lot out of your notes?
-I mean, real --
Yeah, like, just --
You know, I collaborated
with this incredible writer,
Josh Harmon, and the incredible
David Yazbek.
And we sit in the back there,
and we've got our legal pads
or whatever,
and I'm scribbling notes.
And then when I go home, I look
at them and I type them up.
And I was looking at them
one night,
and I don't know how to explain.
I've never said this out loud.
Like, the character
who plays my sister Laura
is talking to little 10-year-old
Sarah, and she says --
she's telling her what she was
like when she was a baby
and "How I used to
change your diaper."
And then she says,
"And sometimes you would fart."
And she would kind of swallow
the end of the sentence.
And so I was looking
at my notes,
and it says, "Laura,
don't swallow fart."
And, yeah,
I took a picture of it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-When I was -- You know,
you're so serious back there.
And then as I'm typing it up, I
just laughed so hard because --
not just at the sentence,
"Laura, don't swallow fart,"
but just how serious
I know I was when I wrote it.
-Yeah.
-I was like...
[ Laughter ]
So, the true story is,
you went to see a hypnotist
when you were 10 years old
as a means of dealing
with this problem.
And was it still
fresh in your head?
Like, do you have
vivid memories of it?
-You know, I don't remember
yesterday or last week
or like four hours ago,
but I remember it so vividly.
And it's funny 'cause it's
a great song in the show --
this hypnotist, Dr. Grimm,
which I didn't change his name.
I don't know, I guess, so far,
it's not been a problem.
And then there's little Sarah.
And I remember this hypnotist,
and I remember him
having me close my eyes
and talking me through.
And there's a stream,
and you walk to a clearing.
And I'm just like,
"What's a clearing?"
I'm 10. Like, I couldn't
figure out what it was.
And then I remember my whole --
desperately trying
to be hypnotized,
but my brain was just like,
"This chair is blue.
He has a penis and balls."
You know, and then I was like,
"How does he wipe?
Do boys wipe front to back
like girls?"
And then, like, "Where does
his front even start?"
And it's this whole
inner monologue,
and it's in the song
and it's so funny.
Every time I watch it,
you know, I still --
That's one thing where I'm like,
"This is, like,
literally my thought."
Like, exactly what was
going through --
-It's authentic
to a 10-year-old.
-Yeah, it was my entire
inner monologue.
-You knew stand-up was something
you wanted to do early on.
Do you remember early jokes?
-Oh, yeah, I was --
I had really terrible --
I don't remember
doing this joke,
but I was looking
at old notebooks.
I don't save things.
I'm not very sentimental,
but I have all my notebooks
since I was like 19,
maybe, or 18.
And there's a joke in there
that's so bad, it made me laugh,
just that it's terrible.
It said, "I don't know
why my goldfish died.
I put it in a tank --
dot, dot, dot -- top."
[ Laughter ]
Just seeing, like --
seeing how I wrote it
how it's to be performed.
[ Laughter ]
-It won't work if you just say,
"I put it in the tank top,"
but if you put those two --
you put those dots in there.
-Yeah, "top."
-I'm always very happy
to talk about your father.
A very funny man
all these years.
A man who loves comedy.
Now, you know,
there's a character
in the show who's him, right?
And has he come and seen
the show, and does he like it?
-He came Friday night,
Saturday matinee,
Saturday night, Sunday matinee,
and Sunday night.
Five shows in three days.
-That is a dad!
You got a dad on your hands!
-Oh, my God.
-A-list dadding, right there.
-I know. I mean,
he's been saying for years,
"How much longer do I have to
stay alive for this thing?"
And now it's like, "Oh,
I'm so glad he's seen it."
But he said it was
the best weekend of his life.
-That's amazing.
Also amazing, and thank you
for sharing this,
these are the texts he sent.
This is April Fools' Day.
-His favorite day.
-And he tried to tell you guys
that your stepmother knocked out
his teeth, right?
-Yeah, so, very upsetting.
"Janice got --"
I can't read well 'cause
I don't have my glasses.
-Yeah, "Janice got pissed at me
and knocked my teeth out.
I'm going to sue her."
And then, "Pic of me
without my teeth."
-That's my favorite is that he
didn't just send the picture.
He wrote "Pic of me
without my teeth."
[ Laughter ]
-And then down here,
it just said,
"I can only eat soup
and ice cream. Very sad."
And then, "Eleeza," "Eliza?"
-Eleeza.
-"Eleeza, you have spaghetti
on your head."
What does that mean?
-That was, like, an April Fools
that he had just with Eleeza.
That was just a sidebar.
-And so his April Fools joke
is to tell --
-She probably was like
[Gasps]
[ Laughter ]
She's 29, by the way.
She's 29.
-Sarah Silverman, everybody.
"The Bedwetter" makes
its off-Broadway debut
on May 23rd at
the Atlantic Theater Company.
We'll be right back
with Jeffrey Donovan.